تتواصلوا معاناه الصيادين الفلسطينيين في
قطاع غزه مع تصاعدي الاعتداءات والقيود
المشدده التي يفرضها جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي عليهم
مباشر عليهم
ومصادرات مراكبهم وادوات الصيدله التي تعد
مصدر رزقهم بل تعدتها الى التقليص المستمر
لمساحه صيد المسموح لهم العمل فيها
القرن الماضي
20 ليلا بحريا تقلصت هذه المساحه تدريجيا
حتى وصلت الى حوالي 85% من مساحه الصيد
المسموح بها
ضمان
طبيعه هذه المتاعب والمصائب التي
يجدها هؤلاء الصياد
رزقهم
ورحلتهم التي تبدو دائما
الى البحر
هذا صحيح عبد الصمد هي فعلا من المهن التي
تعتبر محفوفه بالمخاطر والقلق والتوتر وهي
يصدق عليها القول في كثير من الاحيان
بانها البحث عن لقمه مغمسه بالدم باعتبار
ان هذه الشريحه شريحه الصيادين هي الاكثر
تضررا من سياسات الاحتلال التعسفيه وايضا
من سياسه الحصار المفروض على قطاع غزه منذ
اكثر من 15 عاما على التوالي حتى هذه
اللحظات فالرحله تبدا من هذا المكان
الذي ترونه بعدسه الكاميرا الان وهو حوض
الميناء ميناء الصيادين في قطاع غزه تبدا
من هنا
وتنتهي على بعد سته كيلومترات تقريبا هي
المساحه الوحيده المسموح بها لسياد قطاع
غزه بالوصول اليها وهي مساحه تعتبر من
وجهه نظر الصيادين مساحه فقيره جدا ليست
غنيه بالاسماك باعتبار انها ليست منطقه
صخريه وهي منطقه لمرور قوافل همم او افواج
الاسماك همم وليس الاستيطان فيها والتكاثر
وما شابه ذلك اضف الى ذلك سلسله
الاعتداءات التي يتعرض لها الصياد المركز
ال- ال- ال- ال- المركز الميزان لحقوق
الانسان لوحده على سبيل المثال احصى خلال
عام 22 الماضي احصى نحو خمسه عمليه اطلاق
نار بالرصاص الحي من قبل الزوارق الحربيه
الاسرائيليه على قوارب الصيد الفلسطينيه
في هذه المسافه نحو اكثر من 20 من
الصيادين او 23 اصيبوا بجراح متفاوته
ومختلفه خلال عمليات اطلاق النار وهناك
ايضا عشرات
لم يكن اكثر من ذلك
الاعتداءات على الصيادين اعتقال نحو اكثر
من 40 من الصيادين خلال العام المنصرم
تخريب نحو 26 من القوارب قوارب الصيادين
في اكثر من 16 اعتداء هذا يعني عبد الصمد
بان هذه المهنه فعلا محفوفه بالمخاطر
وايضا هناك تراجع في عمليه الصيد سواء من
حيث الكميه وايضا من حيث عدد الصيادين
الذين يزاولون هذه المهنه على بمقارنه
بسيطه في عام 2000 تقريبا كان هناك نحو
خمسه عشره الف من الصيادين الذين يزاولون
هذه المهنه وكان في ذلك الوقت مسموح لهم
بالوصول الى 20 كيلومتر حسب اتفاقات او 20
ميل البحري حسب اتفاقات اوسلوه لكن الان
تراجع الصيد وانحصر في مسافه لا تزيد عن
تسعه اميال وتقل احيانا الى ثلاثه اميال
ايه بحريه الان نحو ثلاثه
ثلاثه,500 من الصيادين يعملون ويزاولون اي
نحو اقل من الثلث تقريبا الان يعملون في
مهنه الصيد
الاسرائيليين ايضا قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تحاصر هؤلاء الصيادين بعبر
المعابر على سبيل المثال كثير من هذه
القوارب التي ترونها لا تعمل اصلا بحكم ان
همم الالات والمستلزمات غير مسموح
بادخالها عبر المعابر المؤديه الى قطاع
غزه وبالتالي هي همم لا تستطيع العمل
وعليه كثير من القوارب اصلا اصبحت عاطله
وعباره عن قوارب يعني لا غير مستعمل
ومعطوبه وبالتالي هذه المهنه وهؤلاء
الصيادين عرضونا الى كثير من همم
الاعتداءات والخوف وبالتالي هي مهنه فعلا
صعبه جدا جدا شكرا لك وائل الدحدوح مراسل
الجزيره من ميناء غزه